as Jughead completely lost it seems like
it so let's try and figure all this out
together on Sweetwater secrets
[Music]
welcome back river babes
I'm your host Leon Aguilera and this is
the sweet letter Secrets after-show 4
episode 305 chapter 40 The Great Escape
now my head is still spinning from this
episode and I know yours must be too so
hit the comments right away and start
telling me your initial reactions the
game begin now today I'm bringing you
exclusive interviews with KJ Appa and
Lily Reinhart and they're both talking
about our favorite beanie loving weirdo
now as always I'll be unleashing all of
my frustrations and exclamations and
hisses and kisses but first let's recap
all of the outrageous G&G behavior in
the blue and gold breakdown fresh with
her flashback knowledge Betty is
convinced that it's someone in the
midnight club who's creating all this
Griffin's and gar gorillas chaos but
Jughead who is now deep under G and G's
dangerous spell thinks that all of this
has been the work of a rogue Game Master
who's been working on this deadly quest
for years I can decide your mind catch
them so while Jughead decided to host an
epic quest back into elder ver with the
Serpent's Veronica enlisted the help of
her real-life friends to rescue Archie
from juvie oh and Betty borrowed a key
piece of the plan from Jughead I'm
taking your bike just before Archie's
last fight and the rescue plan was about
to begin
Archie was having a heart-to-heart with
his new BFF Joaquin but then the serpent
smooched him and then betrayed him the
warden said if I did this - he sent
through a series of twists and turns and
homemade smoke bombs Archie escaped from
the wardens clutches and we even had an
epic fake-out courtesy of Betty and
Kevin
what we do for you fellas but the
biggest and most confusing twist of this
episode was discovering that the warden
was secretly playing G&G all along
because okay sure he branded Archie was
some weird symbol and then the warden
ascended and took his own blue-lipped
life now with Archie safely hidden in
the bunker the group made a pact to keep
his location a secret and Betty decided
to take first watch as Jughead was
headed home to get some much-needed
sleep he ran into
dun-dun-dun the gargoyle King now let's
move past that Twiggy weirdo and move on
to all the romance in this episode with
seven seconds in heaven you guys it
finally happened after nearly five full
episodes of Riverdale Cheryl and Tony
had their first kiss of season 3 and it
was so incredibly wait what hold up that
was it um hello what happened
we're wind that part so I can see it
again Wow okay cool alright nice I see
how it is I mean at least we got this
line from Cheryl Tony and I were in her
tent having a rendezvous but I'm
honestly really tired of this ish and
okay moving on as for things in barchi
land
Veronica showed up and proved that
brunettes have more fun when they have
some time to kill with their imprisoned
boyfriends hmm I wonder what Bart she
did for those 20 minutes
him and her got it as per bug head well
tensions are running high for our
investigative duo because while Betty
was busy trying to crack the case
Jughead was just acting like he was on
crack okay you're not making any sense
now here's what I'm gonna do
I want to replay you guys something that
Lilly Reinhardt told me about Betty and
jugheads relationship in season three
because when I first sat down with her
for this interview in early October the
stars had just finished filming episode
eight and now her ominous warnings
finally start to make some sense now
let's take a rewind look so they
definitely tackle the one of the bigger
mysteries of Griffins and gargoyles in
battling the gargoyle King together in
season three the first couple episodes
are them
kind of digging deep straight into that
going headfirst side-by-side which is
really sweet to see and they really are
a team something unfortunate happens
which maybe causes a little disagreement
between them and some frustration but I
think there you know every relationship
has some bumps but I think they come out
on the other side pretty well okay so it
sounds like bug head will be able to
move past all this but it's still
interesting going back and putting the
pieces together with Lily's relationship
clues but now let's jump into my rants
and raves of the episode with kisses and
kisses first up hisses to warden Norton
for strapping Archie down and branding
him like cattle and also for having some
weird connection to G&G how did he know
the term read paladin I thought Jughead
made that up and his quest is the bunker
bugged how does this game work I
honestly don't know what the heck is
happening anymore but I do know that I'm
glad that you're dead warden hisses -
Jughead for refusing to take part in the
real-life quest to save his best friend
from jail and instead devoted hours to
playing a make-believe game at least he
seems to be good at it
your deception gambit has paid off this
is - Sierra and Tom's engagement now I'm
not saying I don't like their
relationship it's great I just think
it's absorbs that Kevin and Jose you're
gonna be step-siblings I'm sending
hisses to the fact that we never found
out what happened to Josie's dad and
Kevin's mom can someone please check the
Riverdale court records and tell me if
there are any new divorce filings we
should know about no clue hisses - the
fact that we waited five episodes for a
showy smooch and it was a small little
kiss in the history of the show hey even
Jughead and Ethel's kiss lasted longer
hisses - Reggie Kevin and Josie for
starting their own chapter of G & G -
Joaquin for stealing a smooch from
Archie and then stabbing him and then to
hire him for bribing those boys into
sending Archie to jail go way Hiram and
of course the biggest hiss is going to
the gargoyle King let me get this
straight
is there someone running around in the
forest at night with some kind of cow
skull on its head and some twigs glue
to their hands what is going on is this
a crazy person is this part tree who are
you switching over to kisses that one is
going straight to Betty for letting her
hair down and saving the day in her
serpent jacket and kisses to Veronica
for rescuing her man and shutting down
Ellie O's condescending behavior
thank you for mansplaining my business
to me kisses to Jughead for enlisting
Cheryl's help to prove that he's not
just the serpent king he's also a
fearless badass time to find me again
and kisses to the fact that once again I
could not stop laughing after his stream
to Cheryl kisses to the return of Mad
Dog I'm so glad you're okay and kisses
to the fact that he held off the guard
so Archie could escape best roomie ever
kisses to the short but sweet Shoni kiss
I'll take what I can get and kisses to
finally seeing the return of the
bromance between Archie and Jughead
now here's what KJ alpha had to tell me
about the return of Jughead and Archie's
friendship moving forward speaking of
Archie and Jughead what's their
friendship gonna be like this year it's
a lot of fans really wanted that
bromance to come back she's kind of
excluded from the other three this
season he finds himself alone a lot me
and colleges shot and kind of emotional
powerful scene between the two of them
holding hands on the beer Walker but it
was good because I think it's good cuz
it reminds fans of how good of friends
we actually are because you know we
don't get to have that many scenes and
now we're gonna end it there now thank
you all so much for watching the
Sweetwater Secrets after-show and I'll
see you next time for our preview for
episode 306 chapter 41 Manhunter but in
the meantime please give this video a
like and then hit subscribe so you never
miss an episode of all of this Riverdale
goodness and now hit the comments and
tell me your hisses and kisses for
episode 305 what did you guys think
about jugheads behavior this week are
you oh so pissed about the show knee
kiss who else is glad that the warden is
dead and what are your new gargoyle king
theories tell me in the comments below
thank you so much for always being so
amazing river babes this kiss is for you
[Music]